welcome to best car fixes this is
muhammad haroon idris please subscribe
share and like
today we have infinity q60
and
he the customer brought a key from the
dealer
as you know from the dealer is come only
the remote that the insert key will not
come with it so we are trying to add
this key
so let's go ahead and ignition is on i
will call uh i will come to emo and i
will accept the information and then
from here i will go by vin number
accept
the win
okay you're going to wait a little bit
till communication this is infinity not
nissan
you say hazard right on open close
driver door
just in case there is no key
how the light is on
so now
we're going to say okay
it will calculate
the system i want to know how long it
takes before it's finished
you have to get your own key
cut it
for the emergency key
35 percent
stay there a little bit
okay here now
you can go to imus in my smart system or
just scan emu
so you're gonna start all over
okay uh add a key got it supposed to
have three step
so you're gonna start i'm gonna turn the
key off him i believe
okay let's start
you have to start with the ignition off
it will alert all the key
ignition must be off hazard on open
close the driver door one time
okay so you can attach the the emblem
into the car you say okay
place the back of smart key
against the ignition switch this one
here just put it like this
and then press ok
you're gonna hear noise
you hear that noise
success
operate
press start button
for two seconds or more
ignition will be on
okay
see for two seconds or more
one
two
ignition is on
it says oh yeah yeah
are the ignition on the dashboard
information
information in normal condition detail
on
yes everything turned on
so yes
now you gonna wait
now the second step
turn the ignition off wait three seconds
turn the ignition off
wait three seconds one two
three
push the start button once attach the
smart key need to be programmed to the
button so you got to do like this
one and put it
you see it's a five time blink there
that means this one is registered
so yes
do you wanna
program another key
so this one is already programmed i'm
gonna keep it here
i will say yes
turn the key off wait three seconds
turn the key off
i'm gonna wait for three seconds one two
three
okay now take the other one the last one
that you have it
the same thing push it one time look at
it
push it with the remote amble on there
once and then you're gonna see that
light will blink five times so i'm gonna
push it one time
leave it now you're gonna come on
blinking five times
okay
then you come here and say okay
say yes
uh press okay
we have two key already do you want to
program
another one i say no
turn off
wait five seconds
turn the ignition off
wait three seconds one two three say
okay
press start button and attach the first
key
so now we're gonna take the first key
that is here
within five seconds okay push it
and put this for five seconds
yes
you're gonna push it and do it for five
seconds so i'm gonna say okay
turn the key off wait three seconds one
two three
keep programming succeed perform the
following check open and close the
driver door click the unlock unlock
key once
start the engine and wait five seconds
okay open the door
close it
push lock
unlock
and what is it else
start the engine wait for five seconds
i'm gonna start the engine
i start the engine
wait for five seconds one two three four
five
three steps success everything is good
go back
and you're good to go
thank you for watching best car fixes
mobile electronic diagnostic this is the
part of
cec here i have engine
code in the indian
engine control module i have a code you
can go here
but from here
you see like
variable intake air system you have a
code in the engine you can't do nothing
just clear the quotes
i'm going to turn the key off
ignition on
and then yes
but you cannot go do anything on in this
place only for code clear code
escape all this
uh i'm gonna go back
go back
yes i'm gonna exit here
and then go exit come home
this emo decline
go to diagnose
here is the same here you have to read
another win
where it give you all the information
this is the beauty about this infinity
about this tool you can have diagnosis
and programming at the same time
this is the vin number here say okay
you break down the car infinity qx60
infinity qx6c
you know like almost maybe the same l50
2014 minus this 2014 2014 and up 2014.
okay
even by air model but i don't want to go
into details
because i just want to see what what's
going on
this is to scan the whole car or one by
one you see how many computers
this is even the air box
oh i noticed something
you see the airbag light is blinking
let me start the car
see the airbag light
is blinking right
let's see what happened to the airbus
airbag
read code
occupant sensor unit communication error
occupation occupant sensor communication
error acupuncture communication error
ignition voltage law crash zone sensor
communication error can network
communication error so it have a lot of
codes a lot of codes
what happen if i can clear it
okay i go back
go to airbag
i'm gonna clear it and see
erase the codes
we'll do that
i clear all the quotes
read
so still there so we have a severe
damage on the airbag system please
subscribe share the like now i'm going
to get him an insert key because he
doesn't have it and we take it from
there please subscribe share a like i'll
see you in another video this is
muhammad idris